this is Michael Thompson he was
born this morning his heritage is
good strong healthy stuff no hereditary
defects no family history of abnormality
what kind of person will you be Michael Thompson
after the world has made its impress on you what
kind of a world will you live in this is the
town you will grow up in this is the street
where you'll spend most of your early years this
is the house or you will live your first school
and the people who are the important
people in your world Michael Thompson
there's old mrs. radius who lives next door
she doesn't like children very much then
there is Homer Buchanan who lives nearby
Omer likes children
and there's mr. Perry the milkman and Andy
the groceries clerk the postman who comes
every day and the policeman who directs
traffic at the school every afternoon
and there's a whole succession of schoolteachers
and children in and out of school in a few more
years of baby brothers and most important of all
your father and mother this is your world Michael
Thompson and the important people in it the people
who will love you who will push you and pull you
help you and hinder you in your job of growing to
be a man let's look at your world a little closer
Michael and see what it will do to you let's
start with your father Daniel Thompson and your
mother Elizabeth Channing Thompson they love you
very much Michael they want you very much what
are you so red there's nothing wrong with him
Isla no he's a fine boy I think he's beautiful
yes they want you very much Michael and they
have definite ideas of what they want you to
be and preconceived ideas dreams that will
influence the way they act Michael Michael
F Thompson you're going far son your father
expects big things from you he wants you to
be better than he is to grasp the opportunities
he missed to realize his unfulfilled aspirations
and your mother expects things to she wants
you to love her as much as she loves you to
need her love to need her care now and a
little later and forever dreams Michael
all parents have dreams everyone has dreams most
of the time they don't even know they have them
in a few days they take you home and some of
the most important days of your life begin
you need a nice warm world Michael you need
loving care and gentle affection you need a
happy secure home and your parents give
you everything you need Michael gladly
and easily uncritically because now you are
exactly what they want what their dreams want
everyone knows what a little baby is
like charming helpless and appealing
your father and mother know it too Michael
they don't expect you to be anything else
and then you start to grow up Michael and there's
a wonderful excitement about every
new thing well about almost every
new thing there are some new things that
don't quite fit with your mother's dream
you're growing up now and you don't like
to be coddled all the time he
never lets me hold him anymore
Michael take that dirty thing out
of your mouth let him alone he's
growing up and very often Michael
the things you do the things every
baby does don't always fit in
with your father's dream either
does he have to be so messy about
it he'll let me feed him eat
eat let him along Daniel he's just a baby
first father says let him alone is growing up
and then mother says let him alone he's just a
baby why don't they let you alone each of them
has a dream about what he wants you to be each
tries to mold you according to his dream mother
can't let you be independent father can't wait
until you're ready to do new things remember
mother's dream she wants you to cling to her
forever remember father's dream he wants you to
grow into the ideal he has set for me Michael
you're growing up the way you have to grow
up doing what you have to do exploring new
things going back to old things even when
it's not quite the way your father expects
it to happen even when it's not the way your
mother would like it to be well Michael you
keep on growing and as the years past there
are other times happy times too many of them
when what you really are comes very close to
what your parents think you should be you've
learned to feed yourself pretty well by now
a little closer to your father's dream of you
and when it's time for bed and your mother tucks
you in you come a little closer to her dream
sleep is good Michael when you feel secure
with your parents when you know they love you
but sometimes when you wake up and the night is
dark quiet you get a little uneasy for little
children there's something strange about the
night something unfriendly even your toys don't
comfort you and you need comforting Michael
you watch your father and mother nothing very
special or urgent about it but what will happen
Michael will your father get angry and say get
back into bed right this minute is that what's
going to happen Michael or when your mother get
her worried look and say my baby come to mommy
is that what will happen will they make more
of this moment than is really there or does
this happen what ought to happen you see they
can modify their dreams your father and mother
they can sometimes break away from their fixed
ideas of what you ought to do and be it seems so
easy for them to spend a few moments making the
night seem warm and friendly again so that you
don't mind going back to your room but it isn't
easy when mother wants to keep you a baby and
fathers impatient when you act like a baby as
a matter of fact Michael you're a little of both
sometimes a baby and sometimes quite grown-up no
it isn't easy this business of growing up
it isn't easy in the outside world either
you stay away from my flowers Michael Thompson
gone there is no place in her dreams for children
mrs. Reyes thinks little boys are horrid
monsters who want to trample her flowers
but Homer knows they're not monsters Homer
can accept boys and girls pretty much as they
are and he likes them that way children
don't get in the way of homers dreams
Oh fine bring them down come on we'll put them
on let's put the gloves on
come on give me a white one
that's it
children love homer because he
always lets them try out new
things without forgetting
if they're still children
wonderful man that Homer that's right Michael
take it home that wonderful experience take
it home and share it your father's please he
understands about these things but your mother
is upset because well she doesn't want you to
learn things like boxing boxing God where did
you get those from son oh he did a well let's
put these on and let a real expert show you how
to use them why does your father have that edge
in his voice is he hurt because he wasn't the
first to show you the first thing to do is to
get your position right now why does he have to
make this a lesson lead with your left and cross
with your right go on cross with your right now
the main thing is to keep moving all the time keep
jabbing keep coming in keep your guard up you're
wide open now jab with your right watch your
chin gotta learn to defend yourself watch it now
no it isn't easy to grow up Michael especially
when your father expects so much of you when
he's got a dream he wants very much to come
true and it doesn't quite come true for your
dreams either Michael and in a few weeks now
Michaels mom is going to the same hospital
where she had you you remember the building with
the pipe pillars and she's going to have a little
baby for you to play with that's right Mike
then you'll have a brother to play ball with
don't say that Daniel it might be a girl nonsense
it'll be a boy and we'll name it Robert you're so
sure of yourself why ever since I played with
dolls I've wanted a girl baby dolls don't be
silly Elizabeth when do you see him like you
can teach him to ride your bike and box with
him and all you think about is boxing boxing
within box within box we're box within box
within box with a box with why do you keep
hopping on that you're just confusing the
boys saying things like that of course Mike
you'll have to share your toys with him but
you won't mind that because you've got lots of
toys I don't know why you do it Daniel I really
don't for children the difference between dreams
and reality is very slight so slight that when
the baby brother actually comes Michael isn't
very sure be careful Michael he's very delicate
mustn't touch the baby son yes Michel but he's
a little what dispatch someone as big as you
what did you expect Michael someone as
big and frightening as your daydream
because the attention Michael let that baby alone
he's so little but he can get you in trouble you
think he'll always get you in trouble you think
he must be your enemy will you're frightening
dream always make him your enemy even when you
are both a little bigger will he still be your
enemy a few years later that's the way it can
be Michael when you have a preconceived idea
about something about someone that's the way
it is with everyone without our even knowing it
we try to make things happen the way we expect
them to happen that's the way it is with your
parents - with your mother trying to make you
into her dream with your father trying to make
you like his dream they really don't want the
same boy and you can't make either dream
come true it never happens that way let's
see what it might be like Michael if your
mother's dream were the chief influence in
your life your mother who protects you too
much who worries too much who can't bear to
let you grow up to grow away from her after a
while you even feel guilty about growing up oh
my just think that my boy is big enough for
a suit like that you don't think it's too old
looking for him gee-whiz mom you gotta let
me grow up sometime yes Michael she's got
to let you grow up but she'll do it grudgingly
unwillingly it's the new things like your first
long pants that make her feel lonely and old
she doesn't want to lose you every new thing
every first time is a threat an attack aimed
at her dream how does it feel going to your
first dance son oh all right I guess hey
can I go not exactly no he's not taking a
girl why do you feel so troubled Michael is
it because you know that you're not really
what your mother wants you to be her baby boy
oh you'll go out with girls before very long
but you won't be happy about it
you'll get married too but no matter whom you
marry there won't be much joy in it women make
you feel guilty all women just the way your
mother makes you feel guilty yes Michel that's
the way it would be with your mother's dream
running things let's suppose instead of your
mother's dream dominating things having's always
happen the way your father's dream forces them to
happen remember that night 2 woke up a little
frightened get back into bed get back into
bed right this minute and that day mrs. greatest
chaste you stop sucking your thumb remember when
your new brother arrived Michael let that baby
alone you ought to have better sense than that
you see Michael it isn't that your father doesn't
love you it's just that he expects too much
Michael come back here come here when I call
you what do you mean slamming that door that
way haven't you got any better manners than that
don't answer back that way have you cleaned up
your room be quiet now go upstairs and clean up
that mess it isn't easy with a father who won't
ever listen to you who is never satisfied I know
he wants to go swimming responsibility yes he
wants you to have all the virtues Michael he wants
you to be the strongest the finest the best of all
it's a good feeling when you win Michael when
you're on the winning side your father should
be pleased how many you get son I got a
two-bagger and a couple of singles well
better luck next time never satisfied always
want you a little different a little better
more like his dream but you don't know about
his dream Michael and you're all mixed up
sooner or later you stop trying that's why
you avoid those school dances you want to
go but you're afraid you'll come close but you
won't go in it's hard to do anything when your
father is always saying don't do this don't
do that be the best he's wrong but he makes
you feel the way you do with your product
afraid a sharp tone of voice a disapproving
attitude a person in authority any one of
them can make you feel afraid angry resentful
after a while it won't even have to be your father
or anyone outside of yourself
that makes you feel that left
I am I well to get the raise na quit quit why
what do they do do you didn't do anything I
didn't give him a chance I quit first not
very pretty is it Michael either way mama's
boy or Papa's boy and they wouldn't like
you to turn out either way your father and
mother even though it would be their dreams
that helped to make it that way but let's
go back back to the hospital on that first
day when the nurse took you to your parents
it doesn't have to happen that way Michael
either way because your parents can break
away from the rigid patterns of their dreams
or at least they can learn to hold them back
a little your father and mother don't have to
be parents they can learn that only by bringing
up a child you Michael for your own sake
and they get the kind of grown-up son they
want with parents who help you mature properly
and fully you'll have a warm secure baby world
where you are protected and loved and cared for
a world where you are free to follow the gradual
inevitable path to manhood at your own pace
and with this sympathetic and understanding
help of your parents Michael you can succeed in
overcoming childhood fears you can avoid having
any preconceived ideas that your brother is going
to be your enemy it's difficult for a small boy
to understand what a new baby is going to be
and it's natural for him to be a little curious
of course he cries when you touch him
and you're distressed but your father
will explain things your brother's a little
young to play with just now we sort of have
to take care of him for a while you and I but
you wait until he gets a loner are your parents
loving guidance you can learn to accept your
brother to accept him as a friend and equal
with parents who can modify their dreams to fit
your needs you can lead a happy and productive
life well equipped to make your way in the world
well equipped to make your way in your work maybe
he is really too little but Michael you carry some
weight in your childhood community they accept
your judgment you're a person in your own right
Michael grown and matured in an atmosphere of love
and mutual respect an atmosphere that encourages
you to go forward joyously to manhood and maturity
an atmosphere that prepares you
to find your place in the world
with confidence and the best use of your abilities
you can be a well-integrated man Michael
a whole man well qualified to take your
place in the family the community the
world you see there are three Michael
Thompson's and probably even more
those other two and this one one of
them will be you Michael the others
will of the wisps might have been